What are your thoughts on adding glynec?
A supplement made of glycine and anocetal cystine
and a glycine to give to my supplement regimen.
I was diagnosed with estrogen-driven breast cancer
four years ago.
No, I would not recommend that.
So, again, glycine can be a precursor
for synthesis of glutathione in the mitochondria.
So, there's actually genetic encoding
for mitochondrial synthesis there with glycine.
Glycine isn't a amino acid.
And that's why you would use glycine.
But it can help, again, go back to our lectures
should you increase oxidative stress with cancer
or try to decrease oxidative stress with cancer?
If a person has active cancer,
it's not wise to decrease oxidative stress.
So, I think the person that's asking this question
is it a relative state of remission?
But being in a relative state of remission,
I wouldn't necessarily push glutathione type precursor
supplements and acetylcystine falls into that category too.
So, this particular brand, the glycnec is the brand,
is a brand that is meant to help increase
the antioxidants intercellular antioxidants
and help protect cells from cancer,
because cancer, again, can be caused
from reactive oxygen species for oxidative stress
from toxins in our environment.
However, once you have a diagnosis of cancer,
like we said, those cells are already at a
dangerous high level of reactive oxygen oxygen species
and if you technically took a bunch of glutathione
or glutathione precursors,
you could actually be keeping those cancer cells alive.
But that's why we always suggest test aid.
And this particular person asked this question,
I've tested for these types of products,
maybe not that particular product,
but these types of products that are glutathione precursors
and I did not test well.
So, I would not do that, but not use that.
So, and maybe this person read an article about
this is a great product to prevent cancer
which you would read things about that
in the supplements that are out there
that are supporting glutathione production
or are glutathione supplements
at our supporting antioxidation function in your cells,
would list themselves and would sell,
they would sell the product by saying
their anti-cancer, their cancer protective
which there's truth to that.
But if a person already has cancer,
taking those products could give you, you know,
a greater chance of mortality,
worst diagnosis.
So, I'd be careful with those products.
Also, what are your thoughts of decatinamide riboside?
So, this is an AD plus product.
Again, you are supporting the NAD pathway
which is supporting, again, glutathione production
which is also, this can also support
the veg F production and NOS production.
So, I would not take that as a cancer patient either.
So, like those products that are NADH products,
the products that are nitric oxide products
you don't, yes, you know, from a general perspective,
you don't want to use those products
if you have a diagnosis of cancer.
They can, you know, they can cause
the worst problems for a person.
So, I wouldn't take those, I'm happy to diagnose the cancer.